[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con air france
24 mi nombre es ángela gómez la
situación de la pandemia sigue
preocupando en europa donde a pesar del
avance del programa de vacunación no se
registran aumentos en el número de
contagios en varios países de cara a la
reapertura económica del verano esto en
gran parte impulsado por la aparición de
la variante delta la más contagiosa del
virus mientras unos países optan por el
levantamiento de restricciones otros se
ven obligados a imponer las nuevamente
para analizar el tema conectamos con el
doctor oscar franco epidemiólogo
director del instituto de medicina
social y preventiva de la universidad de
berna académico de harvard e iu de la
universidad de erasmo de rotterdam y
también nuestro asesor científico doctor
un buen día para usted y europa se
debate entre la apertura de cara al
verano y el temor de una nueva ola de
contagios cuál es la situación general
en el continente
buenos dias angela y si la situación es
bastante preocupante parece nuevamente
volverá a salir de control después de un
año como que no aprendimos las lecciones
que tuvimos hemos visto un gran aumento
de casos en todo el continente pero
específicamente en países como rusia el
reino unido chipre países bajos de
españa y eso se debe como decías al
aumento a la llegada de la variante
delta que es una variante más contagiosa
y más agresiva y segundo que encontró la
variante delta pues la vía libre porque
muchos países estaban relajando las
medidas así que vemos la situación con
bastante preocupación
precisamente podemos ver a los líderes
de varias naciones haciendo grandes
anuncios en reinounido boris johnson
continúa avanzando con la des escalada y
habla del fin de las restricciones para
el 19 de julio sin embargo el propio
gobierno reconoce que aumentarán tanto
los casos como las muertes qué opinión
le merece esto
en una sola palabra me parece
irresponsable porque realmente todos
queremos el día de la libertad como se
ha llamado el 19 de julio todos estamos
cansados de la pandemia pero tenemos que
ser realistas con la situación cómo está
y ahora mismo el reino unido está
experimentando más de 30.000 casos
diarios en los últimos días no se ha
aumentado tanto las hospitalizaciones y
las muertes pero sabemos que esto serían
buenas semanas para que se puede
aumentar los casos aumentar las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes ojalá
que no pero ahora mismo yo creo que es
una decisión bastante apresurada bueno y
mientras tanto en francia- de manuel
vacuna anuncia vacunación obligatoria
para los trabajadores de la salud y la
posibilidad de un debate sobre la
inoculación obligatoria para todos los
ciudadanos sería ésta una tendencia en
europa si la situación no mejora
alemania por ejemplo rechazó esa
posibilidad
sin más que la inoculación obligatoria
macrón defiende su decisión es que es la
la presentación del certificado lo que
es obligatorio del certificado de
vacunación o de test negativo esto ha
tenido un impacto enorme porque vemos
común en las últimas horas más de un
millón de personas han hecho ya una una
cita para vacunarse y esto si lo ponemos
dentro del contexto está ocurriendo en
un país que históricamente tiene uno de
los niveles más altos de rechazo contra
las vacunas sabemos que vienen medidas
es posible que se violen las libertades
individuales y esa discusión tiene que
ocurrir como podemos proteger a la
población el interés colectivo mientras
que respetamos la libertad individual de
las personas y también decidir cómo se
van a implementar esta obligatoriedad
para los certificados de vacunación o
negatividad de texto y doctor frank o en
países bajos los casos van en aumento y
el primer ministro mark rutte pidió
incluso disculpas por haber levantado
las restricciones demasiado pronto cómo
está la situación allí donde usted se
encuentra y podría replicarse este
escenario en otros países que apuestan
ahora mismo por la reapertura
y eso es lo que lo mínimo que puede
hacer que era pedir disculpas porque
realmente la situación estaba bien
durante dos semanas y devuelven seis de
junio se levantaron las medidas y dos
semanas después pasamos de 600 700 casos
diarios ahora mismo tenemos diez mil
ocho mil nueve mil casos diarios de
hecho tenemos más casos en amsterdam que
en toda alemania al día de ayer de lo
que se reportó en el en términos del
número de casos se han anunciado nuevas
medidas como que se va a cerrar las
discotecas a partir de las doce de la
noche eso se ha recibido por la
población de dos formas por un lado
sabemos que el virus no duerme entonces
no es que esté durmiendo durante diez
arga después de las doce y segundo la
población joven que quiere ir a las
fiestas y salir pero realmente las
medidas que se están tomando son un poco
no lo suficientemente fuertes yo creo
para la situación que estamos viviendo y
que se podría vivir en cualquier otra
parte en europa ahora mismo doctor
muchas gracias a usted y ahora nos
quedamos a la espera de cómo se
desarrolla la situación de la pandemia
en europa en los próximos meses con lo
que sucede ahora en las vacaciones de
verano gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros ya nuestros televidentes
continúen en france24
[Música]